today we're going to cancel airlines so
if you're on a plane right now
as you listen to this i'm sorry for the
inconvenience but your plane
is canceled mid-flight the reason is
the whole series of arbitrary and
unnecessary precautions they've taken
because of covid
which i got a good taste of last week
flying across the country to and from
it starts really in the airport so the
airports are also canceled so is tsa for
many reasons not just this one
but now you know you go up to tsa now
at least at lax and baltimore i don't
know about the other airports but
and they don't check your ticket this is
part of the covid safety plan
they look at your id but they don't look
at your ticket now how does not scanning
the ticket
protect from covid who knows well i do
know it doesn't
the whole reason they did check our
ticket at security is for safety
allegedly it was needed to stop
terrorists from getting on the planes
because terrorists i guess wouldn't know
how to book an airline ticket
even though the airline the 911
terrorists were all ticketed passengers
but anyway um well are we thinking that
the terrorists are going to take a break
now because of covid
or was the ticketing the ticket checking
step never necessary to begin with
if it wasn't why did they ever do it if
it was necessary why aren't they doing
it now
these questions can't be answered
speaking of unanswerable questions
as you walk through the airport whole
sections are taped off
randomly why because of covid
you can't sit here in these chairs but
you can sit over there in those chairs
it's not like this is going to help
people space out the opposite effect now
people are now you're just condensing
people even more
um so why can't you sit in in these
chairs but you can sit in those chairs
is there some sort of force field around
the acceptable chairs
has a gypsy cast a magical spell on
those chairs protecting the sitter from
kovid
do gypsies even cast magical spells or
am i thinking of wizards
again nobody can answer these questions
then as you get as you board the plane
you get yelled at if you're too bunched
together you know you have to maintain
your social distance as you board the
plane
yes the group of 75 people about to
enter a narrow metal tube
and spend the next six hours sitting
next to each other while breathing
recycled air
must make sure not to come within six
feet of each other prior to that
experience
why then you're on the plane the flight
attendant whose full-time job now is
just to
tell you to keep your mask on informs
you that there will be no beverage
service
well they could serve water but not
alcohol and this is terrible for me
because i had a coupon for free
alcoholic beverage
that isn't the point though well that's
kind of the point but but also
why would serving beer present greater
risk of viral transmission than serving
water
i mean you're walking through the plane
with a with a tray of plastic cups
filled with water
as everybody's breath germs settle on
top of the water like like muck
on a pond a beer would be in a can
wouldn't an alcoholic beverage in a
closed container be safer if anything
than a cup of water
if anything shouldn't they only be
serving beer and whiskey
in fact shouldn't they require that we
drink it
i'm not sure why they would require it
but that would be fun also
um i should note that that some people
apparently think that the fact that
everybody is wearing a mask on the plane
is an invitation for them to discharge
their intestinal fumes at will
somebody on my plane i can say was
farting
with reckless abandon my mask
stood no chance against this somebody
else was eating some sort of garlic dish
okay farts and garlic it was like being
in the worst
scented candle shop in existence and i
haven't even told you about the guy
next to me who lifted his mask up to
cough
okay every time he coughed he would lift
his mask up and then cough into the
into the wide open air a real concept
problem here
okay i started to wonder if our plane
crashed would this guy take his seatbelt
off right before impact
like if masks serve any function then
it's definitely
most valuable and necessary precisely
when you cough
other people uh were doing the opposite
though refusing to take the mask off for
any reason
people were eating with the mask on
because they did give us little snacks
you can't have beer but you have snacks
they were feeding themselves by lifting
the mask and inserting the cracker
underneath the mask it was like i was at
asylum watching hannibal lecter at
feeding time and
i should mention that except for the one
guy already noted everybody else kept
their masks on over their nose for the
whole flight
baltimore and california and then the
flight back as well
i was the only one that i saw that i
taken my mask off every chance i got
i got yelled at by the flight attendant
like three times um everybody else for
like for five hours five six hours
they just kept the thing on no fidgeting
no apparent discomfort
total of obedience everybody on fight
with the thing over their nose the
entire time
i felt like i was seeing the end result
of some sort of insidious social
experiment which
i was but as far as the precautions go
all of it is arbitrary and that's the
case everywhere not just on flights
why do so many places have 10 p.m
curfews now you know
like bars and restaurants aren't open
past 10 in a lot of places because of
covet
does the virus transmit more easily at
night are there coveted zombies that
come out in the dark like an im legend
no but all of this is similar really to
the lap bars on roller coaster rides
is that little bar across your lap gonna
gonna keep you in place when the roller
coaster is zipping around no
inertia does that but the lap bar just
makes you feel better
it's for show essentially that's
actually what everything at tsa is
always about
even before covet i mean one guy tried
to sneak onto a flight with a bombing
issue
and now billions of travelers have to
take off their shoes when they go
through security forever with that kind
of logic they shouldn't be flying planes
at all
one crash should have been enough to
shut the whole thing down but the logic
isn't logic it's pageantry it's theater
it's designed to make you feel better
and also to control you
and personally i'm tired of it i'm sick
of it i'm done with it
i hate it being on a plane is miserable
enough and now with the mask it's even
worse
so cancellations all around to everybody
involved
um well this and and even when this is
all over
that this still just cancellations to
everybody
just just purely out of frustration on
my on my part
hey you uh yeah you you're right you
right there
hit the subscribe button right now do it
do it right now
i thank you for your compliance it's
somewhat appreciated